a late night statement from Vladimir
Putin thanking the nation for standing
United he said in the face of those who
had brought it to the brink
is
and in that short address as ever a
mention for his greatest bugbears Kiev
and the West is
is
a few hours earlier The Man Behind
gravis crisis in the president's 23-year
rule Fargo
had broken his silence with a long audio
message explaining why he'd stopped the
march to Moscow
is
Factor
IES
Australia
earlier on Monday this video of Defense
Minister Sergey shoigu the focus of
pregosian's Roth was released touring
his units no way of verifying when that
was filmed but the purpose was clear to
show him back at work and unruffled as
questions swirl over his future
you'll often hear Russians especially
during tumultuous times quote the old
proverb don't swap horses mid-stream and
Vladimir Putin will want to resist
looking like he's caving into pressure
especially from a man he's branded
treasonous by reshuffling his top
military command right in the middle of
his war in Ukraine
[Music]
was branded a traitor and a rebel his
march on Moscow called crazy and
senseless but pregotin said he'd had
plenty of support from the Russian
public
foreign foreign
[Music]